[Music]
the next time you see that adorable
hummingbird at your feeder remember one
thing
it might take your life
because in this world every bird works
for the government as a spy or a hidden
assassin
what does your pet bird know about your
personal life
where can you have a safe conversation
and
how do birds track your movements
this is what if and here's what would
happen if birds were actually government
surveillance drones
okay sheeple it's time to wake up to
some truth
the government has removed most of the
birds on the planet and replaced them
with highly sophisticated robot drones
and these agents of the state might know
you
better than you know yourself
the birds aren't real movement began in
1976 and revealed the conspiracy
to eliminate all birds with a deadly
virus the university doesn't want me
sharing this information
from 1959 to 2001 the united states
government systematically removed and
replaced our flying friends with these
robotic devices
okay if this were true the cia would
have 12 million birds tracking and
surveilling our every movement
but if you're face to beak with these
spies
how could you establish dominance
with so many birds flying overhead at
all times you could never guarantee
you'd have privacy
yeah and that's the point
according to the lore behind this
conspiracy
president eisenhower approved this
project
knowing that one camera in the sky could
do the work of dozens on the ground
if you want to avoid these eyes in the
sky
you'd need to make a soundproof room in
your home without windows
choose your words carefully when you're
outside and keep all your sensitive data
restricted to your safe room
but
what about that cute bird you have at
home
well i hate to break it to you but
paulie doesn't want a cracker
paulie wants your passwords
if all birds were drones everything
you've ever said in front of this
robotic spy
was recorded and sent off to the
government
yeah that's right big brother has been
in your living room this whole time
and when you go outside
you'd better watch your step
some cultures believe that bird poop
brings good luck
the odds of getting hit are astronomical
so a little splash from above must mean
good fortune right
well in this world this liquid would
double as a tracking device made for the
birds to follow you around
if it hits you don't wash your clothes
burn them fast and run fast
if your car takes a splat well call an
uber and ditch your ride because
you may have been designated public
enemy number one
and all birds don't have the same job
bird truthers state that vultures were
created for public sanitation
but hummingbirds are the hitmen behind
this conspiracy
carrying out government contracted kills
and don't be fooled by their eggs
those would be highly detailed replicas
of the real thing
wait can i still eat omelets
i mean if you were in the middle of this
massive cover-up
how could you protect yourself
now if a bird stares at you in plain
sight
don't just sit there
you would need to look directly into the
camera
i mean it's eyes and say i know your
secret
this passcode might scare off the secret
government agent
but while that would take care of one
bird
it wouldn't be enough to protect you for
the rest of your life
if birds weren't real
you would need to keep your head covered
and
choose your words carefully to avoid
further consequences
you know some conspiracies are so
far-reaching that they spread across the
entire globe
i mean disk
what if the earth were flat
well don't peer over the edge just yet
because
that's a story
for another
what if
you